there you see tyler anderson's numbers
and they are awfully nice numbers get
the era down in the threes
and has been doing a great job of uh
being aggressive
challenging hitters with all of his
pitches
one two is grounded onto third a couple
of hops gonzalez comes to meet it
throws it on to first gets the out one
away so he is through carlos santana is
coming up
stabbed no problem two outs
quick hands that ball looked like it was
pretty hit pretty hard sometimes it's
hard to tell it looks like you know
there's a line drive back in the pitcher
and you don't realize sometimes if it's
hit little off the end or
maybe on the hands oh he's aboard it
first with two away for jorge soleil the
cleanup man for kansas city
and to third for the force at second
gonzalez to fraser and the scoreless top
of the first for
tyler anderson back at pnc park
pittsburgh pirates getting to
ready to hit in the bottom of the first
inning and jacob junis will make his
fourth start of the year pitching in his
sixth game his record 1-0 and a 3.71
era there's a swing and a miss and
frazier
down swinging to start on that fastball
in 92 came inside
jacob junis working with salvador perez
there's a swing and a miss on a slider
struck him out so jacob does start well
with back-to-back strikeouts to open the
bottom of the first
well he's got some good stuff that was
the hard slider so reynolds
works that two out walk colin moran
coming up lefty battery at 266.
there's a line drive to center field and
a base hit the rebels gonna be waved
home here comes taylor's throw to the
plate it is strong but
reynolds avoids the tag and moran into
second base with an rbi
single it's one nothing pirates yeah
great
great job by reynolds getting around
that tag stalling sets up away in the
pitch
swing and a miss just a weak wave on a
down and away fastball and he struck him
out
well anderson finally gets his man two
down
bounce to short newman
that's good work tyler anderson
jacob with a k delivers to jacob with a
c here's the 1-0
and a swing of the ground ball that's
going to sneak through base hit
between short and third stalling's
aboard with the lead off single to left
now for polanco they're going to put
three on the right side they're tough to
beat because then they exploit
your weaknesses there's a liner that
gets through base hit hit between second
and short
so two on nobody out the number eight
hitter kevin newman
of the pitch tough guy to strike out but
junis gets him looking
that's jake's third it locked him up now
you've got
tyler anderson and as you can imagine
he's a pitcher not a very good hitter
over six this year with five strikeouts
that will be a strikeout on a foul ball
with two strikes on a bunt
so two on and two out for adam frazier
and there's a line drive that's going to
be caught by merrifield denies the
pirates of any more
he's on base those are high on base guy
in the miners here's
fastball high ball four so a four pitch
walk to lopez
their oldest son their oldest child
there's a ground ball to the second
baseman
this is frazier throwing to first for
the nikki will go to third but now with
two down
so runner at third with two down let's
see if carlos santana who's red hot see
if he can bring him home
and the pitch and a swing and a
roller fair up to third base line third
baseman long throw and safe at first and
a run scores
boy that was a tough play for gonzalez
the third baseman
pulling him to his right throwing off
balance from foul territory a great
effort
but couldn't quite get carlos santana as
the throw
pulled the first baseman moran off the
bag and it's a well-earned rbi
infield hit that ties the game 1-1 off
the bat of carlos santana
it's not usually something a guy does
when he's in his first year with a new
team
tunis will have to hurry and he throws a
strike over to santana reynolds thought
he was safe
jake jonas fielding his position well he
had to get off the mound over to the
third base side in a hurry and then get
rid of it in a hurry and he did
two up two down junis has not had a one
two three inning yet
giunis is looking for his first 1-2-3
inning this time around he gets
moran lefty's 2-2 is swinging a chop
on toward third backing up gonzalez and
they'll throw
on to first to get the out one away
and hunter dozier is coming up yeah the
san francisco giants
starting play today two balls two
strikes here's the 2-2
to dozier swinging a miss kept going
away
and dozier strikes out for the second
out
that'll bring up michael a taylor 1-1
game in the fourth
and the liner to center two out single
taylor is aboard
and hansar alberto the number seven hit
her match in this one-one tie in the
fourth
pretty big lead for taylor he's going
the pitcher's swung on lofted out
to shallow center field long run for a
trio of pirates it's reynolds who slides
he slid on his knees and makes a catch
reaching over his head
and that's how the inning ends you can
watch him coming in and it looks like
there could be
a collision it's look out look out
you've got infielders coming up there
outfielders that's the time to use
that's when you go
first taylor going all the way got a
great jump off first
so a 1-1 game royals and pirates first
of a two-game series eric gonzalez her
third baseman leads off the fourth
hits a two-hopper to the shortstop nikki
lopez and he fires a strike to first for
out number one and
jake junis has really settled down since
he gave up back-to-back singles
in the second inning he has retired
seven in a row could swing
grounder two third right at alberto he
will fire across to santana
and june is really a good rhythm and a
good groove right now
make it eight in a row he has set down
and that'll bring up their right fielder
left-handed hitting gregory polanco
down he goes on three pitches and only
six total for genus and a one two three
four there's one start i think he did it
three
three or four times and that's been
about it and the swing and a miss
went back to his normal delivery and
lopez a one-handed wave and he
strikes out junice will have to swing
away here with the mace's empty one out
he's over seven in his career
anderson's gonna show him why he's a
pitcher right here that
is why you're a pitcher almost no time
to react when it's hit that hard even in
the outfield i would think
a swing and a miss dozier will be thrown
out
catcher to first base to complete the
strikeout so tyler anderson with his
fifth strikeout
two down and colin moran drove in the
pirates run in the first inning
and the base hit into center field very
similar to
his rbi single in the first he is two
out of three and
that'll bring up eric gonzalez
got him jacob junis has struck out eight
the lead off man aboard for polanco one
out of two with a single tonight
blanco's down on strikes for the second
time and junis has struck out nine
there it is right on the outside part of
the plate that nice little
cutter so jacob genus does a nice job he
comes out with runners in first
and third and one out scott barlow will
come on and face wilmer defoe
there goes the runner from first and
it's driven to
shallow left center field and it drops
for a hit
rbi pinch hit single for wilmer depot
stalling scores 2-1 pirates
defoe now four for 12 as a pinch hitter
here we go
it's the ninth inning and the pirates
leading kansas city 2-1
and the pirates will turn it over to
richard rodriguez
who will face michael a taylor three two
swing in the miss he struck him out
raise
the jolly roger rich rod does it again
the pirates are over 512-11
and beat the best team in baseball